Welcome back to the Deep Dive.
This is where we take your
source material, really pull it
apart.
Look at all the pieces.
Yeah, get down to the essential
architecture.
Exactly.
So you can be truly well
informed and today, wow, we are
wrestling with something well,
profound, I think, and frankly
kind of confusing A.
Big shift.
Yeah, A.
Huge shift in American political
aesthetics.
We're talking about the flag,
the founders, you know, the
actual language of patriotism.
Things that felt very settled
for a while, or at least settled
in certain circles.
Right.
For what?
The better part of the last
maybe 2 decades, especially
among, let's call it the
credentialed cultural
establishment national symbols.
They were often viewed with,
well, skepticism.
Sometimes outright disdain even.
Yeah, patriotism felt provincial
suspect.
Totally.
The flag was suspect.
The National History was mostly
something you apologize for.
A source of critique, primarily.
Suddenly, I mean really
dramatically, that seems to have
flipped.
Completely inverted.
We're seeing what your sources
are calling The Great Patriotic
Heist, this same establishment
now enthusiastically waving the
flag.
Quoting the founding document.
Engaging in these, you know,
really robust, very visible
displays of Americana.
It's striking.
It is, and it forces the
question.
Which is our mission today,
right?
To figure out the core intent
here, and maybe more
importantly, the potential
consequences of this this
inversion.
Is it real?
Is this a genuine, maybe
necessary civic evolution?
Like a fundamental heartfelt re
engagement with the country's
identity.
Is it theatre?
Or is it just strategic
political theatre?
A calculated costume change, you
know, designed purely to win
back the Cultural Sunderground.
Performance versus reality.
Is it real or is it performance?
That's the core question.
And that tension right there
between genuine belief and let's
say calculated performance,
that's really the philosophical
bedrock for this whole deep
dive.
You really had to start with a
serious warning, a philosophical
one from Jean Paul Sarge way
back.
He gave us this key principle
for understanding this kind of,
well, self-conscious political
turn, he said.
You become what you pretend to
be.
So be careful what you pretend
to be.
Wow, OK, that lands heavily
here.
It does, and it's not hyperbole.
Not in the context of American
civic life, anyway.
We're a nation that has, in many
ways, always acted itself into
being.
Performing our way into
existence.
Almost.
Exactly.
Performance isn't just, you
know, deception here.
Historically, it's often been
the very first stage of
becoming.
So if the progressive
establishment is now pretending
to be patriotic.
Right.
Adopting the rituals, the
language, the symbols.
Then the danger isn't just that
they're being hypocritical.
No, the deeper danger, the
Sartrian danger, is that they
might succeed entirely, that the
costume, as you put it, could
actually fuse to their skin.
Changing not just their election
strategy.
But their very ontology, their
fundamental being.
OK.
Ontology, the nature of being,
that's yeah, that's a heavy
concept, but I see why it's
critical here.
It really is.
So we're exploring these two
powerful competing viewpoints
based on the sources you've
provided, right?
One argues this new patriotism
is essentially bad faith, a
dangerous performance, a
strategic lie that risks
creating this kind of
self-righteous new orthodoxy.
The negative view.
And the other viewpoint argues
no, this is necessary.
It's civic pedagogy.
It's a vital lesson in how the
Republic actually renews itself
by.
Contesting ownership of its own
ideals.
Exactly following a long
historical pattern.
So to cut through all this
complexity, to really understand
how we got to this very
specific, almost choreographed
moment, we need a map A.
Framework.
Yeah, a framework, and the one
that seems most useful here from
the sources is the Hegelian
dialectic.
Thesis.
Antithesis.
Synthesis.
Precisely.
Think of it like a historical
pendulum swinging back and
forth, sometimes violently.
OK, this model lets us track the
progression phase by phase, how
the political culture shifted,
leading us right to this current
wealth.
Strategic Inversion.
OK, let's unpack that history.
Opposition reaction The starting
point, the dominant culture, say
through the 2010, the system
that kind of invited the
backlash.
Right.
The sources defined this as the
thesis, the managerial moral
order.
A managerial moral order.
OK.
And this period, it's really
about this seamless merger,
almost high velocity.
And merger between what?
Between global capitalism on one
hand and progressive virtue on
the other, they just flowed
together.
So this class, it wasn't defined
by ideology in the old sense,
like left versus right.
Not primarily.
It was more defined by
expertise, by control over
processes.
Technocratic.
Very technocratic, deeply
moralizing too, and
fundamentally therapeutic and
how it approached governance.
What does that mean?
Therapeutic governance?
What does that look like?
It means you govern less
through, say, bold political
commands, and more through
administration, like managing
people.
The goal if you wanted to run
society, was to treat it like a
huge HR.
Department.
An HR department?
Seriously.
Yeah, the focus was all on
compliance process, internal
audits, and maybe above all, the
mandatory display of empathy.
Display being the keyword there.
Absolutely, it had to be seen,
it had to be performed according
to the rules.
And how did this, this
managerial class view things
like patriotism, national
identity?
With suspicion.
Deep suspicion.
Often it was seen as a threat
really, to their global
technocratic project.
Well, patriotism.
You know the kind, filthy, the
average person.
It was dismissed, seen as
provincial sentimentality.
Something quaint, maybe a bit
embarrassing.
Exactly.
Suitable for, I don't know,
local sports teams, maybe
veterans parades, but not for
serious people dealing with
complex global issues.
The sources called it the low
church religion of the
unenlightened.
Ouch.
Yeah, a belief system for those
who lacked the right
credentials, the right degrees,
the right understanding of
sophisticated global
interconnectedness.
So if you were part of this
class, your focus was
international.
International equity, climate
protocols, Complex policy
analysis.
You handle the important high
minded global virtue stuff.
While the uncredentialed masses
back home.
They were sort of left to handle
the cultural plumbing, the
messy, nostalgic, maybe slightly
embarrassing sentimentality of
flag waving.
There's a real sense of
hierarchy there.
Absolutely, and the problem was
their governing style.
Even with all the language of
inclusion and empathy, it felt
inherently paternalistic.
How so?
It basically tried to replace
things like faith, tradition,
maybe local identity with
credentialing.
If you have the right degrees,
use the approved language, the
latest acronyms, the current
terminology, then you were
deemed virtuous.
Yeah, capable of leadership.
And if you didn't?
You were relegated to the realm
of the managed the people who
needed guidance.
And this approach, predictably I
guess, had a crucial
consequence.
Yeah, a fatal 1.
Politically speaking, it bred
deep widespread moral
resentment.
Moral resentment, OK, the
sources really highlight this.
The population being managed,
they eventually started to
notice something that this
mandatory empathy, it always
seemed to flow downward from the
credentialed to the
uncredentialed.
Never outward or upward.
Rarely outward, almost never
upward.
And this polite, process driven
paternalism coming from the
aware classes, it started to
feel less like enlightened
leadership.
And more like.
More like what the sources call
a soft despotism of tone.
A soft despotism of tone.
Let's break that down because
that's a really critical
insight, I think.
It is.
It's not about, you know, tanks
in the streets or obvious
oppression, no.
Secret police.
No, it's about language
policing, institutional norm
control, that pervasive feeling
that you are constantly being
corrected.
Or implicitly accused of some
kind of moral failure.
Exactly.
Just for existing outside of
that specific managerial bubble.
Think about the shift from
debating policy substance to
what, to mandatory sensitivity
training.
The replacement of political
argument with compliance
procedures.
It's control, but exercise, not
by force.
But by mandatory performance,
you have to perform the right
kind of sensitivity.
Precisely.
You felt constantly monitored,
not by the state, maybe, but by
the relentless moralizing gaze
of your own institutions.
Your HR department like you
said, your university, your
social media feed even.
Yes, and that simmering
resentment, that feeling of
being perpetually managed,
corrected, judged.
It created the perfect
conditions for the backlash, the
inevitable backlash.
Which brings us right to that
counter reaction, the
antithesis, the populist revolt.
Right.
And this wasn't just one thing,
it was this collision of
grievances, different groups,
different complaints, but
finding common ground.
Fueling movements like Bernie
Sanders on the left and much
more visibly, obviously the Man
G movement on the right.
Yeah.
And what's really fascinating,
looking at how the sources frame
it, is this idea that the
movement was fundamentally about
recognizing a shared enemy.
Transcending the usual left,
right divide.
For a moment, yes, the
dispossessed left angry about
globalization, economic
extraction, feeling left behind.
And the alienated right?
Angry about cultural
marginalization?
Feeling look down upon
dismissed.
They looked across that
political chasm and they saw the
same target.
The credentialed moral
technocracy.
The managers.
The people who ran everything
and seemed to judge everyone.
And that shared recognition?
It led to something powerful, at
least temporarily.
Yeah, the source is called the
Populist Alchemy.
It was like the first attempt at
a new synthesis.
An alchemy?
Mixing what?
Mixing that old populist left
anger about economics, anti
globalism, pro worker sentiment
with the populist rights,
cultural defiance embodied by
the flag, by traditional faith,
by the idea of sovereignty.
So a coalition forged basically
in the shared experience of
being looked down upon by the
elites.
Pretty much shared resentment as
a binding agent.
And into this steps Donald
Trump.
The perfect symbol, perhaps?
He really channeled that energy,
didn't he?
He became the image of the
unapologetic American.
The guy who refused to adopt the
new moral language.
Refused compliance, defied the
managers, and in doing so he
became the perfect antagonist to
that managerial thesis.
He was maybe for a weird brief
moment, this kind of feral,
almost post ideological middle
finger aimed right at the center
of power.
Yeah, that captures some of it.
And that moment, the anger, felt
authentic to many.
But, and here's the but.
Here's where that Sir Train
warning starts to echo again,
because as the sources
meticulously detail the tragedy
of this revolt, what was it is
that it seemed to quickly freeze
into self caricature.
The rebellion itself became a
kind of costume.
OK, I want to push on this a
bit.
How do the sources draw that
line?
When does an authentic movement
stop being about substance?
And become addicted to theater.
Yeah, how do you know?
That's a crucial distinction,
and the analysis suggests the
transition happened when the act
of defiance became an end in
itself.
Rather than a means to actual
reform.
Exactly.
The original populist energy,
left and right, wanted to
fundamentally change how the
country was governed, how the
economy worked.
But the costume?
Yeah, the persona of the
unapologetic rebel.
It was just too rewarding
emotionally, politically,
socially within that tribe, the
movement got addicted to the
theater of defiance.
They enjoyed making the managers
angry more than they enjoyed the
hard work of actual governance.
That seems to be the argument.
The performance took precedence
over the policy.
It became about triggering the
elites owning the libs rather
than building something new.
So it did break the old orders
monopoly on meaning.
It absolutely did that, smashed
it in some ways.
But it became a performance
obsessed with maintaining its
own image, the perpetual
outsider, even when it held
significant power.
Right.
And that breach, that successful
interruption of the managerial
monopoly, that's precisely what
forced the center, the
establishment, to attempt its
own strategic reversal.
Which brings us back to the main
event, the counter antithesis,
the great patriotic Heist.
The inversion.
This is where we return to that
core observation.
The progressive left the
establishment.
They realized they had an
existential problem, A.
Political survival problem.
They could no longer just mock
the flag or the founders or
National History without
seriously alienating the public
right, especially those working
class voters they desperately
needed to win elections.
The dismissal strategy wasn't
working anymore.
It was backfiring.
So the decision was made.
If you can't beat them, Co
optim.
Steal it back instead.
The strategy was to steal it
back.
This feels like a pure strategic
inversion, a highly
self-conscious pivot in
aesthetics.
Oh absolutely.
And you see the aesthetic
changes everywhere now, like.
What?
Give us examples.
Well, the progressive left is
now actively blending its social
justice rhetoric with
Revolutionary War iconography.
Like tricorn hats at a climate
rally.
Maybe not that literal, but you
see things like No kings, that
old revolutionary slogan
repurpose for very progressive
causes.
You see inclusive 1776 art
installations.
OK, you hear media commentators,
people who maybe spend years
criticizing America's founding
or history, now suddenly, quite
sincerely it seems, referring to
our Republic without a trace of
irony.
And the meaning of patriotism
itself is being shifted, recast.
Fundamentally recast to align it
with that managerial worldview
we talked about.
So it's no longer primarily
about, say, shared sacrifice or
military strength or national
competition less.
About that and more
strategically packaged, well
this source is called, call it
progressive therapy.
Progressive therapy?
How does that work?
Patriotism as therapy.
Think about it.
When the credential class feels
anxious about populism, rising
climate instability, maybe
institutional collapse, the act
of claiming national symbolism,
saying no, we are the true
patriots.
We defend democracy.
It's an act of emotional
regulation.
It soothes the anxiety.
OK.
It makes them feel better, more
grounded, more in control.
Exactly.
It shifts the emphasis away from
say, land of the free in a
traditional sense towards
something more like safe space
of the self aware.
We aren't celebrating what the
country is.
Maybe warts and all.
We're celebrating what we
believe the country should be.
And by asserting that ideal
loudly and patriotically, we
feel morally superior and maybe
less anxious about the parts we
don't like.
Which locks us right back into
that philosophical core, the
Sartrian trap.
Bad faith as national mood.
Precisely.
You said earlier bad faith isn't
just hypocrisy.
We need to give the listener A
clearer sense of that because
it's the existential threat the
sources seem to be warning
about.
Right.
Bad faith or movies fois, in
Sartre's French, isn't really
about lying to other people.
It's about lying to yourself.
Sartre defined it as the self in
flight from its own freedom.
We know deep down, maybe
unconsciously, that we are
constantly defining ourselves
through our choices, that we are
fundamentally free to be
otherwise.
But freedom is scary.
That responsibility is heavy.
Terrifying for Sartre.
So to escape that burden, we
adopt fixed roles.
We pretend the role is us, like
a waiter, a professor, a
politician.
We act the part so completely
that we convince ourselves the
role defines us, erasing the
terrifying freedom to choose
differently tomorrow.
We stop questioning the role.
So the classic example is the
waiter who tries so hard to be
the perfect waiter.
He stops questioning whether he
is a waiter.
He just becomes the waiter.
He fuses with the role, loses
his freedom within it.
And for the progressive
establishment performing
patriotism now?
The danger isn't just that
they're faking it badly or
hypocritically.
The real danger is what the
sources call ontological
experimentation.
Ontological experimentation.
Trying on a new way of being.
Exactly.
They're trying on this patriotic
costume, and they might actually
succeed in making it permanent,
fusing with it.
And why is that success
dangerous?
Because it could be spiritually
dangerous.
In a sense, the identity of this
class for a long time was built
on critique, on rebellion
against tradition, on a moral
superiority derived from
identifying historical failures
and injustices.
But now they're being forced
into affirmation or choosing
affirmation.
They're choosing to perform love
for the very thing they or their
recent predecessors often mocked
or critiqued, or at least
choosing to perform that love
very publicly.
And the performance might work
too well.
It might work so completely that
they actually transform into
what they're pretending to be.
Leading to a new kind of
orthodoxy, a rigid 1.
Exactly.
The original managerial moral
order, fuse, technocracy, and a
certain kind of virtue.
This new version, this synthesis
we're heading towards, it risks
fusing progressive morality with
a kind of forced compliance.
They might become the
bureaucratic, self-righteous
patriots they are currently
mimicking.
Enforcing a patriotism of
paperwork, of correct opinions,
of institutional alignment.
That's the Sartre and Trap laid
bare.
OK, but now we have to pivot
because there's a powerful
challenge to this whole Sartre
and warning, right?
Absolutely the opposing view,
which the sources also explore
in depth.
Which argues that this
performance is acting.
It isn't necessarily deceptive
or dangerous.
In fact, it might just be how
America works, how it's always
worked.
That all genuine civic renewal
starts by acting the part first.
That's the core idea, yeah.
And here we bring in another
philosopher, George Santiana.
OK, what did he say?
He had this insight.
Nothing was ever born without
pretending to be something else
first.
Interesting that nothing was
ever born without pretending.
The historical argument based on
that is that in America, before
you get a deeply held, unified
national belief, you often get a
shared ritual, a performance.
Something you do together, even
if you don't all believe it the
same way yet.
Exactly.
A performance that allows the
belief to actually form over
time.
What looks like cynical mimicry
today?
Might just be the necessary
muscle memory, the practice
required for conviction to
actually take root tomorrow.
That's the counter argument, and
in this longer view, the idea
that the flag must belong to
only one faction, say
conservatives or the right.
That's just historically
illiterate.
Completely according to this
perspective, the flag as
described in our sources is more
like a battlefield symbol.
Always being fought over.
Constantly being fought over,
seized, remade by each
generation to fit the crisis of
its time.
So the progressive move isn't
necessarily theft.
It's simply the latest turn in
an ancient, ongoing contest for
ownership.
OK, to really appreciate that,
we need to slow down and trace
that history.
Look for moments when the
vocabulary of belonging, what it
means to be American, was
successfully grabbed and
redefined.
Especially by those who didn't
traditionally seem to own.
It all right, let's start at the
beginning, 1776 to 1865, the
founding and was often called
the second founding.
Right.
And patriotism, Then it began
fundamentally as an act of
rebellion, no?
Kings.
Exactly.
Profoundly pro accountability
and a tyranny, it was a shared
commitment to a constitutional
ideal.
And the key here, the sources
note, is that early American
identity was civic,
constitutional.
Yes, defined by shared ideas and
laws.
Not by ethnicity, not by
bloodline.
That was crucial.
Then comes the Civil War, the
ultimate contest over what that
constitutional identity actually
meant.
Absolutely.
And Lincoln's Gettysburg Address
that's presented as the ultimate
act of reappropriation, of
redefining patriotism.
He reframed patriotism not as
celebrating a finished, perfect
thing, but as moral continuity.
Unfinished work.
Exactly defining the country is
unfinished work, a debt owed to
the ideals of equality laid out
in the Declaration.
He essentially stole the
founding fathers back from the
slaveholders.
You could argue that by
insisting that the nation score
identity, its reason for being
was dedicated to that
proposition that all men are
created equal.
That was a profound, strategic
and necessary act of
redefinition.
Absolutely necessary for the
union, survival and moral
purpose.
OK, moving forward, 1890 to
1945, the Progressive Era in the
World wars, a very different
time.
Totally different.
Mass immigration, brutal
industrialization, huge wealth
inequality.
Society was fracturing.
So just waving the flag from
1776 wasn't going to cut it
anymore.
It wasn't enough to unite
people.
Not enough.
The era demanded a new
narrative, a new definition of
what patriotism required.
And reformers stepped in.
People like Jane Addams,
Theodore Roosevelt, they
pioneered with the sources
called Social patriotism.
Social patriotism?
What's that?
They explicitly linked loving
your country with social service
with civic duty.
So patriotism means?
It means cleaning up the slums,
ensuring public health, building
and supporting public schools
for everyone.
It became about service to
others within the national
community.
Taking care of the nation's
people.
Right then the world wars came
along and solidified.
This collectivism demanded huge
sacrifice for the national
effort.
But as the sources remind us,
this collective patriotism
wasn't always inclusive.
No, it often came at a moral
cost, the most glaring example
being the tragic internment of
Japanese Americans during World
War 2.
Patriotism defined who belonged,
but also who didn't.
OK then we hit 1945 to 1975 Cold
War confidence and
counterculture post war boom.
Yeah, and for a brief moment,
the flag seemed like a settled
symbol again, almost like a a
corporate logo.
For what?
For American prosperity,
democracy, consumer goods being
sold around the world, it was
kind of flattened,
commercialized, maybe taken for
granted.
And that flatness, that
confidence, made the collapse
during the Vietnam era even more
spectacular.
Exactly the moral authority of
that commercialized corporate
flag was shattered for many,
which led directly to the
countercultural revolt.
Flag burning protests.
Yes, but here's the paradox the
sources want us to really
grapple with What is it That
flag burning?
While obviously deeply offensive
to many Americans, for some who
did it, it was actually an act
of higher patriotism.
How can burning the flag be
patriotic?
It was framed as an appeal to
the Republic's own unfulfilled
ideals.
Liberty.
Dissent.
Constitutional protection.
Peace.
So they were saying this flag
represents ideals you are
betraying.
Essentially, yes.
I care about the promise of this
country, the idea of this flag,
so much that I am willing to
commit this shocking act to
challenge the state when it
betrays that promise.
It's a complicated claim, but
historically significant.
OK.
Then the next phase, 1976 to
2001, from the Bicentennial to
9/11.
This era feels largely defined
by a kind of therapeutic
nostalgia, according to the
analysis.
Therapeutic nostalgia.
Yeah, the bicentennial in 76 was
partly a national attempt to
heal, to get over the trauma of
Vietnam and Watergate.
Lots of tall ships and
fireworks.
And Reagan tapped into that.
Masterfully, he skillfully
merged that nostalgia for a
simpler pass with a narrative of
economic prosperity and national
strength.
He effectively monopolized the
emotional terrain of nationalism
for a while.
And where was the left during
this period?
Well, having associated the flag
so strongly with the Vietnam
War, with the military
industrial complex, maybe with
that corporate logo idea, they
largely retreated.
Retreated into what?
Into identity politics, mostly
focusing on group identities
rather than a national one, they
effectively ceded the entire
concept of national belonging,
the language of patriotism,
almost entirely to the right.
And that dynamic mostly held
until.
Until 911, which very briefly
forced a kind of unity, a unity
through shared grief, a
temporary truce in the culture
wars, everyone flew the flag.
But it didn't last, no.
That trust, that unity, it
eroded pretty quickly,
especially with the controversy
over the Iraq war and then the
2008 financial crisis.
Which seemed to prove that the
managerial class wasn't just
moralizing, but maybe also
incompetent.
Yeah, it damaged their
credibility significantly, which
sets the stage for the next
phase. 2008 to 2020.
The moralization of politics.
Obama's era.
Rise of social media.
Right.
Obama's rhetoric certainly tried
to revive a kind of aspirational
civic pride, the hope and change
idea.
But the Coalition fractured.
It did the post crisis
environment, the rise of social
media amplifying divisions, it
fractured and cultural
progressivism gained dominance
within that establishment
sphere.
Focusing on.
Focusing heavily on defining
virtue through the lens of
systemic oppression.
Recognizing privilege.
Being aware of historical
injustices.
Which had a direct impact on how
patriotism was viewed.
A huge impact patriotism itself
became in many influential
circles recoded as privilege,
meaning displays of national
pride were often scrutinized,
seen as naive at best, or maybe
willful ignorance of ongoing
injustices at worst.
So the flag became suspect
again.
Explicitly suspect symbolizing
for its critics things like
white male authority, systemic
racism, military aggression, all
the things the managerial class
built on critique instinctively
rejected.
Which brings us right up to the
present moment. 2024 to 2026 The
Reclamation Project.
The Great Patriotic Heist in
action.
And the shock that forced this
change, this reclamation, it
wasn't primarily moral.
No, the sources argue, was
purely strategic, a cold
political calculation.
The establishment realized.
They realized they had ceded the
fundamental language of
belonging, of national identity.
They left the field wide open
for the populist right to define
what it means to be an American.
And that was politically
suicidal for them.
So they had to get back in the
game.
Had to steal the symbols back
and the new progressive line.
It's a political masterstroke
really built on that historical
precedent we just walked
through.
What's the line?
Democracy itself is patriotic.
Protecting democracy is the
highest form of patriotism.
So the goal isn't to reject the
national story anymore.
No, that failed politically.
The goal now is to embrace the
story but insist they are the
ones best suited to finish it.
Finish it How?
Every civil rights advance,
every Environmental Protection
measure, every social justice
initiative, it's framed not as
an anti American critique
anymore, as an act of
completion, honoring the
promise, fulfilling the ideals,
cashing that promissory note
that King talked about.
And the sources argue this
reappropriation, this heist, is
defensible because it's how
things have always worked.
Entirely defensible from that
historical perspective, they
point to strong precedent for
reappropriation.
Like Lincoln, as we discussed.
Lincoln reappropriated the
Founders.
FDR, with his four freedoms,
explicitly redefined the flag to
include economic and social
welfare.
He connected patriotism to the
right to a job, a secure home.
He made the New Deal patriotic.
Exactly.
And Martin Luther King Junior's
promissory note sermon may be
the most powerful example
describing American ideals as a
debt, a check written by the
founders that keeps bouncing.
And demanding the nation honor
its own commitment.
Yes, the argument is the current
progressive turn is just the
latest iteration of this.
Maybe adding a layer of
self-awareness?
Maybe corporate efficiency?
To this ancient American habit
of redefining what the flag
means.
They're performing necessary
civic pedagogy, teaching the
nation what patriotism should
mean.
Now that's the defense.
OK, so we've got the
philosophical warning, Sartre's
bad faith and the historical
defense.
Santiana's performance as the
start of becoming. 2 owerful
lenses.
Now let's really dig into the
present moment, analyze the true
nature of this new synthesis,
this progressive patriotism, and
let's start by acknowledging the
case for it, why it might
actually work, or why it might
even be sincere or at least
strategically necessary.
Right.
And the first big reason the
sources cite for why this
performance might stick, why it
might be more than just a
performance, is the realization
that guilt alone fails.
Guilt alone fails.
Meaning the moral exhaustion of
the 20 tens, that relentless
focus on historical wrongs, the
constant atmosphere of apology
and critique.
It proves something.
What?
That you can't sustain a
political consensus, let alone
govern effectively when the
primary unifying emotion you
offer is collective shame or
perpetual self critique.
Critique is easy, maybe, but
governance needs something more
positive affirmation.
Exactly.
If you want to mobilize a
diverse country, you need to
offer a shared path forward, not
just a shared apology for the
past.
So reframing progressive goals,
Equality, environmentalism,
social justice.
Reframing them as expressions of
national pride rather than as a
renunciation of a flawed past
that builds an absolutely
crucial emotional bridge.
Back to the mainstream, back to
people who might have felt
alienated by the constant
critique.
Precisely.
It replaces that feeling of
endless correction with a sense
of aspirational unity.
Let's Make America fulfill its
Promise is a much more inviting
message than America has always
been terrible.
OK.
That makes sense strategically.
What's the second point?
2nd is the strategy of updating
the Canon, expanding who counts
as a founder essentially.
How does that work?
When the establishment starts
quoting figures like Frederick
Douglass, Susan B Anthony, WEB
Dubois, right alongside
Jefferson and Madison.
They're making a statement.
They're making an explicit
argument the American Revolution
was interrupted.
It wasn't finished in 1776 or
1787.
So this isn't about diluting the
founding.
No, the argument is that it's
about extending it, that the
Canon of American ideals is
inherently expandable.
Every major civil rights
advance, every expansion of
liberty.
Is framed as honoring the
Founders original intent, even
if the founders themselves
didn't fully live up to it.
Exactly.
It's completing their work,
making the promise real for
everyone.
And that makes the American
creed, the core ideas more
portable, more accessible to a
really diverse, pluralist
society.
Absolutely.
It transforms the national
narrative from one may be
centered on a few white male
land owners.
Into a continuous story, a story
of contested liberation, a
struggle that includes everyone
who fought to make the country
better, closer to its ideals.
A belief in liberty and equality
that transcends ancestry or
origin.
That's really the only kind of
patriotism that can work in a
truly diverse modern nation.
That's the argument OK.
And the third reason why this
might be working. 3rd, they are
actively, consciously closing
the emotional intelligence gap.
The EI gap between whom?
Between the managerial left and,
well, the rest of the country,
perhaps for too long, that
establishment seemed to believe
that superior policy papers and
charts and facts would
automatically win the day.
The technocratic belief and
reason, right?
But they learned a painful
lesson, especially in the Trump
era.
Which was?
Facts persuade, maybe, but
feelings mobilize.
Emotion drives politics far more
than logic does.
So a democracy run purely by
spreadsheets and policy briefs?
Cannot, in the long run, outlast
one fueled by powerful symbols,
shared songs, deep visceral
affection, even if that
affection is sometimes messy or
irrational.
So by reclaiming national
symbols, the flag, the anthems,
the history.
The establishment is realizing,
or perhaps relearning, that they
have to master the emotional
language of belonging.
You have to speak to the heart,
not just the head.
You can't govern a story you
refuse to tell.
Exactly.
And now they're actively trying
to write themselves back into
that national story in a
starring role.
OK, that's a strong case for why
this might be effective, maybe
even necessary from their
perspective.
It is but.
But that strategic mastery
immediately leads us back to the
critique.
The critique of artifice.
The uncomfortable reality of the
second synthesis.
Right.
If this is indeed working, if
this performance is succeeding,
what exactly are we creating?
What does this new synthesis
look?
Like and the sources define this
outcome as.
As synthetic patriotism.
Synthetic, meaning artificial
manufactured.
Pride that is managed by
professionals, belonging that is
distributed through
institutional channels with
rules and guidelines.
OK, where do we see evidence of
this synthetic quality?
Well, look at the slogans.
They're noble enough.
Sure.
Defend democracy, freedom for
all, love of country, love of
justice.
All good things, but notice they
are also inherently antiseptic.
Antiseptic clean.
Sterile.
Exactly.
Carefully curated focus group
for maximum compliance and
minimum offense, minimum risk.
They lack the the raw quality,
the messy, maybe even dangerous
energy of spontaneous belief or
fierce dissent.
Precisely.
It's the difference the sources
draw between the quote sweaty
beer stained patriotism of
barbecues and gun ranges.
That kind of unmanaged
grassroots emotion.
Versus patriotism as a brand
activation.
Managed, clean, predictable.
The flag.
In this new context, it risks
becoming What was the phrase?
A corporate logo for decency.
Woof, a corporate logo for
decency.
Sterilized focus grouped.
Safe for all institutional
investors in HR departments.
That's the critique.
And this synthesized patriotism,
if it takes hold, inevitably
produces what the sources
satirically call the United
States of HR.
The United States of HR.
That's a powerful image.
What does it imply?
It implies that the danger isn't
necessarily malice or evil
intent.
It's professional control.
It's management taking over
everything.
So freedom in this context gets
redefined.
It suddenly gets redefined as
the right to participate safely
in the collective performance of
virtue.
Safely meaning.
Meaning within approved
boundaries, following the rules,
using the right language.
Think about it.
It's a managed environment.
Consensus is strongly preferred
over messy contestation.
Belonging is granted or
validated through compliance
with institutional values.
So your patriotism isn't
demonstrated by, say,
sacrificing for the country or
challenging power.
No, it's demonstrated by using
the correct approved language,
attending the mandatory
diversity and inclusion
workshops, aligning yourself
visibly with the current
progressive orthodoxy.
And all of this is done under
the banner of defending
democracy.
Right.
Democracy becomes synonymous
with compliance with the
approved institutional
narrative.
This tension then culminates in
this bizarre fusion of
opposites.
Yeah, ostensibly you have the
woke manager in the corporate
office and the Mad J trucker out
on the highway.
And now they're both performing
love for the same country,
waving the same flag.
They might be, but the critical
point is they love it or perform
loving it for fundamentally
opposite reasons.
OK, explain that the manager
loves the country because.
The manager in this framework
loves the country for its
potential, for what it should
be, its capacity for moral
correction, for progress.
They love the ideals yet to be
achieved.
I love the distance between the
flawed reality and the perfect
aspiration.
You could say that they love the
project of improvement managed
by people like them and the.
Truckers, the populist, They
love the country because.
They love its defiance, its
history of rebellion against
elites, against that managerial
class, its freedom as they see
it to speak unfiltered truth, to
reject centralized control and
process.
So 1 loves the potential for
managed perfection, the other
loves the freedom of unmanaged
defiance.
Exactly.
And the synthesis that tries to
contain both of these opposing
instincts, that's where the
looming danger lies.
Which the sources identify as a
new form.
Of moral.
Nationalism, moral nationalism.
OK.
We need to linger on this
because this feels like the core
risk they're outlining.
It absolutely is.
It's the fusion of that
progressive empathy or the
performance of.
It with centralized control,
with management.
Yes, unity achieved not through
shared identity, maybe, but
through pervasive supervision,
through ensuring everyone
adheres to the same moral
framework.
So moral nationalism insists
that for the country to be good,
you must adhere to a specific
set of moral precepts defined by
the managers.
Precisely.
And if you question the policy,
if you descend from the values,
if you use the wrong language,
you're not just a political
opponent anymore.
You're a moral failure, an enemy
of democracy itself.
That's the danger.
This kind of patriotism doesn't
primarily ask you to fight for
the country, it asks you to
comply with its certified
institutional values.
It transforms critique not into
debate, but into compliance.
That's the end point of
synthetic patriotism, according
to this critique.
OK, so Hegel's dialectic keeps
rolling.
Every synthesis hardens becomes
the new thesis, the new status
quo.
Which inevitably creates the
conditions for its own
opposition.
Yeah.
So now we need to look at the
consequences if the progressive
establishment actually succeeds
in this, if they achieve the
professionalization of
sincerity.
Yeah, and this is the great
irony.
The sources point out the
institutional left, which maybe
wasn't great at winning the old
culture war on purely economic
or traditional grounds.
They are profoundly adept at
institutionalizing things.
Masters of it, even something as
seemingly unmanageable as
rebellion or authenticity, they
might actually succeed where the
populist right failed.
How?
By making authenticity itself a
bureaucratic mandate.
Exactly.
By professionalizing sincerity,
turning it into a measurable
outcome, a policy goal.
So we have to ask that really
difficult question, what
actually happens when anti
establishment sentiment or the
performance of it becomes a
civil service requirement?
Yeah, when the symbols of
rebellion, maybe even quitting
radical thinkers, are approved
and distributed by the
establishment itself through
official channels.
The flag becomes just another
compliance symbol.
A check box on the corporate
diversity audit.
Patriotism becomes a managed
brand asset, demonstrating the
institution's alignment with
approved values.
This is where that Sartreon
warning about pretending comes
roaring back.
It transitions into the true
prophecy of bureaucratic
patriotism.
The danger isn't that the
performance remains.
Hollow.
No.
The deeper danger is that it
becomes real, but real in the
worst possible way.
How?
So.
Self-righteous.
Pervasive.
Institutionally inescapable.
Managed from the top down.
It transitions from a chosen
performance, maybe strategic, to
sincerity by decree.
Yes, the flag hangs in every
classroom, every corporate
lobby.
Not because of organic love or
local pride, but because it's
policy.
It's mandated.
It's a nationalism that might
quote James Baldwin or Audra
Lord instead of Thomas
Jefferson.
But it still demands the same
kind of top down obedience,
often enforced, as the sources
suggest, with extensive
mandatory paperwork, training
modules, compliance reports.
It's a nationalism that comes
with that friendly, empathetic,
managerial smile.
But that smile has an audit
trail attached.
Performance reviews based on
demonstrated alignment.
So this new orthodoxy, even with
its language of democracy and
inclusion, it's still
fundamentally about control.
Control enforced from above by
the managerial class defining
the parameters of acceptable
civic thought and behavior.
And this enforced virtue, this
managed patriotism, it
immediately creates its own
vulnerabilities.
Its own potential weaknesses and
honest risks.
It plants the seeds of its own
destruction.
And the primary risk as outlined
in the sources you gave us?
Is sanctimony.
Sanctimony.
Self righteousness.
The inherent belief that moral
virtue belongs exclusively to
one political tribe, the self
aware, the educated, the
credentialed, those who use the
right language and hold the
right opinions.
And if this new patriotism
ossifies, if it hardens into
what the sources call a
sermonizing technocracy?
Where every national symbol
comes with a mandatory lecture
on its proper interpretation.
It risks recreating the very
thing that caused the backlash
in the first place.
Exactly.
It risks recreating that soft
despotism of tone, that feeling
of being constantly lectured and
managed that birthed the
populist revolt.
History as we know, as a dark
sense of humor.
It loves to repeat its
contradictions.
And that failure of
self-awareness, that potential
for sanctimony, it guarantees
the inevitability of the next
revolt, the next antithesis.
Because every managed
authenticity, every enforced
sincerity, eventually breeds its
opposite.
So once inclusive patriotism,
this synthetic managed version
becomes the default civic
orthodoxy, the expected
performance in every school,
every workplace, every
institution, a fresh.
Rebellion is almost certain to
erupt, probably from the margins
again.
And who leads this next revolt?
What does it look like?
The sources speculate it might
come from the genuinely
apolitical, or maybe the post
political the young maybe those
completely burned out by the
endless culture wars of the
previous generation.
Maybe veterans disillusioned
with all political performances,
those who feel fundamentally
alienated by the performance
required by both the managerial
left and the populist right.
They reject the whole.
Game.
They reject not just the woke
moralism and the Maggie A
populism, but the entire
machinery of choreographed
political performance itself.
They're looking for purity,
maybe.
Yeah, something the sources
describe as brutally real,
stripped of hashtags and
choreography.
Something authentic that isn't
managed or branded.
Yes, a generation that finds
managed patriotism, however
well-intentioned, completely
suffocating.
It might not wave any flag at
all.
Or they might find an entirely
new symbol, something that
represents a quest for sincerity
completely unchanted by
political management or
corporate branding.
It's possible they'll seek an
authentic expression of self or
community that is defined
neither by compliance with the
new order nor by nostalgic
defiance against it.
Something else entirely.
But underneath all this back and
forth, this thesis, antithesis,
synthesis, the core truth
remains that this constant
contest is the American
metabolism.
That's a great way to put it.
The country doesn't actually
seem to reconcile its deep,
painful contradictions.
You know, slavery versus
liberty, wealth versus equality,
individualism versus community.
It does what instead.
It markets them.
It performs them.
The performance becomes the
product, the brand, and
eventually that product.
That performance becomes the
accepted creed for a while.
So the strength of the Republic
may be paradoxically.
Is that the flag never gets to
rest, that it remains violently
contested?
That it has to insist on meaning
different things to different
people all at the same time.
That seems to be the argument.
The left's current embrace of
patriotism isn't the end of the
story.
It can't.
Be it's simply the next
necessary chapter.
Ensuring that the unfinished,
contested, maybe unresolvable
business of America just keeps
going.
The dialectic continues.
Hashtags tag outro.
Wow.
OK, so we have journeyed all the
way from the managerial thesis
of the 20 tens.
The HR department running the
world.
Right through the messy, defiant
populist revolt.
The breaking of the old
consensus.
And landed squarely in this
current synthesis a kind of
multicultural, corporately
managed patriotism, designed, it
seems, to restore order and
reassert a specific kind of
moral authority.
Yeah, the sources have given us
really profound map, I think,
for navigating what feels like a
confusingly synchronized, almost
choreographed civic landscape
right now.
It really clarifies the
underlying dynamics.
And we end by locking right back
into that core philosophical
tensions, Sartre on one side,
Hegel on the other.
Performance versus historical
process.
And the vital recognition from
both.
Really, every synthesis is
temporary.
It will become the new thesis,
and every act of bad faith,
every sustained performance of a
chosen role, eventually risks
hardening into ontology.
It rewrites who you are.
It fundamentally rewrites the
culture it seeks to inhabit, and
we are watching the American
identity try to rewrite itself
right now in real time through
this performance.
So our final take away for you,
the listener, based on
everything we've unpacked today,
is this, this new patriotic
synthesis.
It will likely be highly
successful, at least in the
short term.
It will look good on camera.
It'll be promoted everywhere.
It will feel safe, reassuring to
many.
It will sound profoundly
sincere, especially coming from
institutions we trust.
And according to the critical
analysis we've explored today,
that very success, that
seamlessness, that sincerity,
that is precisely why it could
be dangerous.
Because the moment the line
vanishes, the line between the
chosen role of the virtuous
patriot and the live reality of
bureaucratic control and
compliance.
The new orthodoxy is born, maybe
without us even noticing the
shift.
And that leaves us and you with
that central unresolved dilemma,
the question the American
dialectic seems to always circle
back to the question for you to
consider long after this deep
dive ends.
When you're faced with the
nation's deep contradictions,
its hypocrisy is in its
aspirations.
Which is worse, the lie that
offends or the truth that
terrifies?
Because the pattern suggests we
Americans will continue to act
out the answer first, perhaps
for a long time, before we ever
find the courage to name it
truthfully.
So we encourage you observe how
performance shapes reality in
your own life, in your
communities, and your
institutions, and recognize that
this contest over the flag, this
messy ongoing struggle over who
gets to define what this
Republic means.
That struggle is the Republic.
It might be the greatest and
most necessary duty of being.
Our subject today is, is
something quite visible lately,
this shift within the American
progressive establishment,
specifically the well, the
sudden and quite enthusiastic
embrace of patriotic symbols,
nationalistic rhetoric.
You know, we're seeing figures,
institutions that maybe once
treated the flag or the founding
documents with a certain
skepticism, now quoting
Jefferson without apparent
irony, holding no kings rallies
and using the phrase our
Republic quite frequently,
almost almost defensively, it
seems sometimes.
Mm Hmm.
And it's definitely not a minor
shift, is it?
I mean, the source material
we're looking at frames as
phenomenon, not just as some
kind of a political rebranding
exercise, but potentially as a
real turning point in the
American dialectic.
It forces us, I think, to ask
some pretty fundamental
questions about political
sincerity and maybe even the
nature of civic duty itself.
Absolutely.
So the core question before us
today, the real heart of the
debate is this.
Does this new progressive
patriotism represent a frankly
dangerous act of what the source
material calls bad faith?
You know, a calculated
performance that's just destined
to harden into a kind of
self-righteous bureaucratic
orthodoxy.
Or, alternatively, is it
actually a necessary, perhaps
even genuine act of civic
pedagogy, a kind of reclamation
that's actually required for the
Republic self correction?
Right.
And I'll be arguing that what
we're seeing is essentially A
genuine and I think necessary
civic evolution.
It follows a pattern we've seen
before, historically speaking,
the idea that, well, all civic
renewal begins as performance.
And I'm going to argue that this
is better understood as, let's
call it the Great Patriotic
Heist, a synthetic and I
believe, deeply dangerous
political maneuver toward what I
worry could become a kind of
sincerity by decree.
OK, well let me start then by
laying out why I think this
shift, even if it looks a bit
awkward or, you know, stage
managed at first, is actually
fundamentally necessary very for
the political body to survive.
Critics might dismiss it as
mimicry or just calculated
politics, but I think it could
very well become what the source
calls muscle memory.
And that's really how genuine
belief systems often form.
The historical context, I think
really supports this view.
If you look back, all
significant civic renewal tends
to start as ritual, as public
performance, before it really
hardens into deep conviction.
The material reminds us of
Santiana's observation, doesn't
it?
That nothing was ever born
without pretending to be
something else first.
In a way, we're performing the
future we hope to inhabit.
I can see why history might seem
to provide, well, a permissive
framework for this, but I tend
to frame it quite differently.
For me, this shift seems driven
much more by a kind of deep
narrative panic, you know, a
panic that really set in after
the the populist revolt expose
this massive vulnerability in
the establishment's, let's say,
emotional connection to the
country.
So what we're witnessing, I
think, is some pretty profound
ontological experimentation the
progressive establishment is
deliberately trying on this
patriotic costume that maybe
they secretly fear, or perhaps
desperately hope will eventually
just fuse right onto their skin.
But hang on, is it just trying
on a costume, or is it perhaps
an act of reclamation?
Because that seems deeply woven
into the fabric of American
history.
I mean, think about our major
moments of moral progress.
Lincoln, for example, he
effectively reappropriated the
founders from the slaveholders
who claimed exclusive ownership,
didn't he?
He defined the nation not just
by who we were then, but by the,
quote, unfinished work we owed
to the world.
Or Martin Luther King Junior
using America's foundational
ideals, the Declaration itself
as a kind of promissory note, a
debt the country simply had to
honor.
What we're seeing now, well, it
looks to me like the latest
version of that same process,
not some sudden, out of the blue
invention.
But.
Isn't there a key difference
there that historical
reclamation you mentioned, it
was largely driven by outsiders,
wasn't it?
Abolitionists.
Civil rights figures, people
forcing the system to bend
toward its own stated ideals,
using those ideals almost as a
weapon against the existing
establishment.
This current shift, it seems to
be coming from the inside.
It's the establishment itself
performing the change.
And that difference feels
crucial to me.
It brings us towards something
like, well, Sart's concept of
bad faith.
And this isn't just, you know,
simple hypocrisy, which implies
you know the truth and
consciously choose to lie.
This feels more like that
Sertrian bad faith, the
establishment choosing to hide
from the, let's face it,
difficult truth that they are
actively performing this
identity right now.
They're playing the patriotic
role so completely, almost
desperately, until the role
itself becomes mandatory, a kind
of self-imposed cage.
It feels like an attempt to
negate their own past critiques
by adopting the aesthetics of
the very system they once seemed
to oppose.
OK, I hear you on the cage
metaphor for national identity,
and I agree any codified civic
identity certainly risks
becoming restrictive.
But isn't that choice of
identity also necessary for
stability, for survival even?
Why is choosing an aspirational
patriotic identity, especially 1
based on the proposition of
equality, necessarily a cage
rather than, say, a necessary
foundation?
Because the danger, as I see it,
isn't that the performance is
hollow or fake.
The source material actually
suggests it might become real in
the worst way.
If this shift actually succeeds,
the worry is that it
institutionalizes a kind of
moral nationalism that fuses
empathy with control, and that
leads directly to what the
source rather chillingly names
the United States of HR.
Think about that.
This isn't a state controlled
by, you know, jingoistic
military figures.
It's potentially a kind of soft
despotism where compliance with
a very specific set of approved
progressive values, things like
diversity metrics or
environmental stewardship
targets, gets mistaken for
genuine freedom.
The flag in that scenario
becomes almost like the logo for
internal corporate compliance.
I just don't quite buy that the
primary outcome here is going to
be some sort of totalitarian HR
department running the country.
I suppose I come in it from a
different angle.
The practical and frankly, the
emotional necessity, guilt
alone, relentless critique.
That just can't hold a complex
democracy together, can it?
Especially not in today's
fragmented information
environment.
You need some level of
affection.
You need common songs, common
symbols.
This new patriotism, I think, is
simply the latest attempt to
translate that old idea that
America is a proposition, not a
tribe.
We simply need something more
visceral, more felt than
spreadsheets and policy papers,
if we want to outlast the appeal
of, say, raw ethno nationalism.
OK, I understand prioritizing
that need for affection to fill
what you see as an emotional
vacuum.
But let me push back a bit on
the nature of that necessity.
If this is truly about meeting a
desperate emotional need, why
does it feel so, well,
inorganic?
I mean, I challenge the
sincerity by calling this
synthetic patriotism.
It feels like pride that's being
managed by communications
professionals, distributed
through institutions, think
tanks, media platforms.
It feels less like a genuine
change of heart and more like
the establishment learning the
right kind of cosplay, if you
will, needed to absorb the
aesthetics and the emotional
power of the populist revolt,
its antithesis, and ultimately
neutralize its energy.
It looks like a calculated
institutional defense mechanism,
not some spontaneous civic
awakening from below.
Well, it might be calculated,
sure, but calculation doesn't
automatically negate its
function.
The performance itself can still
serve a crucial and I'd argue
necessary function with the
source calls civic pedagogy.
How do citizens learn shared
ideals and values?
Often through public rituals,
through symbols, through
declared affections, even if
they feel a bit forced at first.
This current shift looks like an
explicit effort to reframe
equality, inclusion, and
environmental stewardship as
expressions of profound national
pride rather than renunciations
of it.
And that seems like building an
absolutely essential emotional
bridge back towards the
political mainstream, especially
after the let's call it moral
exhaustion of the 20 tens, when
progressive politics often felt
defined almost solely by
critique and rejection.
But that calculated reframing,
that synthesis you describe,
that's precisely where I see the
danger lurking, because it
attempts to sanitize control.
I have to disagree pretty
profoundly about the likely
outcome of this synthesis.
I see the current blend, this
mix of progressive moral
vocabulary with a kind of
populist aesthetic or affect, as
basically an extension of the
founding promise.
It's making explicit what many
have argued all along, that the
original American Revolution
was, in a sense, interrupted,
not finished.
The source material itself
points to the deliberate
inclusion now of figures like
Frederick Douglass and Susan B
Anthony.
Alongside Jefferson is, you
know, proof that the Canon is
being updated, made more honest,
not diluted.
To me, this looks like an
inclusive moral nationalism, an
aspirational step towards the
nation we're actually supposed
to be.
That's certainly a compelling
argument for the intent behind
the update, I grant you that.
But I'm just not convinced about
the benevolent outcome, largely
because history tends to show us
how power actually works.
And I'd bring up the Hegelian
dialectic here, which, as you
know, dictates that every
successful synthesis eventually
becomes the new thesis, and,
crucially, every performance
becomes the new orthodoxy.
We're not just debating abstract
ideals here.
We're debating managerial power
structures.
This new patriotic synthesis, I
worry, risks being monstrous
precisely because it
institutionalizes compliance.
It seems to demand obedience to
a specific, very current set of
progressive moral values.
In that world, the flag stops
being a symbol of, say, defiant
risk or even shared, complicated
history, and instead become
something more like a corporate
logo for decency.
OK, the idea that this
aspirational patriotism will
inevitably morph into an
instrument of oppression, I
think that underestimates the
foundational American, maybe
even human resistance to
mandatory belief.
We are, after all, a nation
pretty much built on
disagreement.
You're concerned about control.
It's valid, of course it is, but
it has to be weighed against the
necessary function of having any
shared story at all.
You're focusing on the
managerial risk, but I'd argue
the attempt to create some kind
of shared aspirational narrative
is actually a necessary
safeguard against the sheer
nihilism that can be born from
constant shame and self
flagellation.
But the specific danger, I
think, lies in the
institutionalization of this
managerial moral order precisely
because of who seems to be
leading the charge this time.
The left arguably has always
been better at
institutionalizing things, you
know, creating nonprofits,
staffing government agencies,
shaping HR policy.
And that means potentially they
might actually succeed where the
right failed by
professionalizing sincerity.
And when you professionalize
sincerity, the patriotism risks
becoming mandatory.
The flag becomes, as I suggested
earlier, the compliance symbol,
and that results in that
dangerous synthesis, sincerity
by decree.
It might look like a friendly
face, sure, but ultimately it's
a smile with paperwork attached.
How can you really have freedom
if dissent itself gets labeled
as unpatriotic or even worse,
simply noncompliant?
I absolutely understand the
skepticism toward any kind of
top down morality, I really do.
But have you fully considered
the alternative threat?
The danger of emotional nihilism
frankly seems far greater to me
than a few bureaucratic hurdles.
A Republic that dedicates itself
only to critique, only to self
dissection.
Well, it eventually forgets how
to love itself, doesn't it?
So this new move, even if it
starts out feeling synthetic,
seems to me to be seeking a
critical middle path, somewhere
between jingoistic chauvinism on
one side and debilitating shame
on the other.
It seems to acknowledge what the
source calls the emotional
intelligence gap in recent
progressive politics,
recognizing that maybe we need
to provide some positive
affection for institutions if we
expect them to survive rigorous
criticism.
If we just reject this kind of
civic evolution out of hand, we
risk leaving the entire field of
national affection to those who
define love of country in the
narrowest, most tribal, and
often exclusionary terms.
You worry about soft despotism.
I worry more about civic
evaporation altogether.
But civic love enforced by the
managers, well, that isn't
really love, is it?
It's soft despotism disguises
communal improvement.
And for me, that brings us right
back to Sartre, your original
warning.
When you choose to negate your
own freedom by simply assuming a
pre written role, you risk
becoming enslaved by that very
performance you're arguing for.
A necessity that I fear in
practice risks erasing genuine,
necessary dissent.
And I believe the effort to
redirect populist energy and the
national story toward pluralism
rather than just letting it
devolve into nativist nostalgia
is probably the only viable path
towards self correction we have
right now.
The performance, however clumsy
it might seem initially, might
be the only tool available to
forge some kind of common
language again.
So we've explored this.
This profound tension between
historical necessity, as you see
it, and political sincerity, as
I worry about it, inherent in
this pretty dramatic political
shift, Let me just reiterate the
Sartre and warning that really
guides my position here.
Pretending long enough to be
patriotic risks erasing the line
between the political role and,
well, personal reality.
It risks hardening calculated
bad faith into a kind of
mandatory national culture, the
potential for a multicultural,
corporately managed patriotism
that enforces sincerity by
decree.
That feels like a profound
threat to genuine freedom and
authentic civic descent.
We have to remain vigilant, I
think, against the flag becoming
just a symbol of required
conformity enforced by those who
are best at managing the
paperwork.
And I'll reiterate the what I
see as the necessary historical
perspective.
This country tends to digest its
contradictions by fighting about
them, usually quite publicly.
The flag survives and maybe even
remains useful, precisely
because it remains contested
territory, meaning different
things to different groups of
citizens at different times.
So whether this progressive
patriotism is ultimately just a
strategic rebrand or signals A
genuine revival, well, it seems
to me part of the long, often
messy American pattern of self
correction.
It reminds us that loving your
country, in whatever form that
takes, is maybe the shared duty
of everyone who argues about its
meaning, even, and perhaps
especially those who started out
as the country's sharpest
critics.
Indeed, and the material makes
it quite clear that this debate
leaves a core tension
unresolved.
Really, for the listener, it's
that tension between two
different forms of political
threat which is ultimately worse
for the future of the Republic,
the lie that offends or the
truth that terrifies.
And regardless of our
intellectual conclusions here
today, the country itself, as it
always seems to do, will
probably just act it out.
Archer.
And Hegel, quite powerfully, I
think, to look at the left's
turn towards patriotism, asking
if it's performance or, you
know, genuine evolution.
It's definitely ambitious,
philosophically deep, but that
ambition brings challenges,
especially with complex
frameworks.
Maybe we start there with the
clarity of the structure.
Right, the Hegelian dialectic.
It's the backbone here.
Thesis, managerial moral order,
antithesis, populist revolt.
But then it gets a bit intricate
with the synthesis.
Yeah, that's the friction point
for me.
The dialectic is a great tool,
but the way the sequence unfolds
here, well, it needs clear
signposting.
So topic one, while the Hegelian
application is strong, the
structural terms need
streamlining for clarity.
OK, so the material calls the
populist revolt MAGA the
antithesis, but then labels MAGA
itself the first synthesis.
It's actually, And then you get
the Great Patriotic Heist as a
counter antithesis, which then
leads to synthetic patriotism as
the second synthesis.
And look, the concern isn't that
it's wrong.
Maybe reality is that messy.
But the weakness is that this
dense layering risks confusing
even a careful reader.
Which synthesis is the main
event?
Where's the focus?
It kind of blurs the path to the
final point about progressive
patriotism.
But isn't that complexity part
of the point, reflecting the
actual messiness of, well, now?
Are we trying to oversimplify?
I don't think it's about
oversimplifying reality, it's
about sharpening the writer's
argument about that reality.
So the suggestion is streamline
The terms make the progression
towards that final synthesis,
the progressive 1, crystal
clear.
Right, because that's the real
subject under the microscope
here.
Precisely.
So one concrete way, maybe just
label the populist revolt the
full antithesis, then reserve
synthesis only for the final
synthetic patriotism.
That gives you a cleaner thesis.
Antithesis Synthesis arc focused
on the main argument.
OK, see that.
But what if the author really
wants to keep both MAGA and
progressive patriotism as
distinct synthesis showing sort
of parallel resolutions?
That's definitely possible.
It's a sophisticated take, but
if they do that, the text
absolutely has to spell out what
specific contradiction each
synthesis resolves.
Like, OK, MAGA resolves this
tension, pause.
Now, moving on, the progressive
synthesis addresses this
contradiction.
So explicitly signpost each
stage and its function.
Exactly.
Make the complexity a feature,
not a bug.
By guiding the reader through it
very deliberately, it reinforces
the analysis instead of
obscuring it.
OK, structure clarified.
Let's shift gears slightly.
What about the the weight and
placement of the core arguments?
I'm thinking specifically about
the Sartre and warning versus
the historical counter argument.
Yeah, that's the second big
area.
You've got these two really
powerful perspectives, Sartre on
the existential danger, Santiana
on historical renewal.
But they feel kind of separate,
and that separation, I think,
actually weakens the punch of
the main argument.
The main essay You become what
you pretend to be.
It sets up this really stark
warning, performative patriotism
becoming real, but in the worst
way, very urgent.
Super urgent that existential
threat lands hard.
But then much later we get this
detailed counter section.
The whole reinvention of the
flag piece.
It's thorough, it's historical.
But it arrives so late it almost
feels like a different essay.
And the weakness there is that
it unintentionally dials down
the urgency of the initial
Sartre and warning.
It shifts the focus from
philosophical danger to, well,
historical precedent.
Almost like civic lessons, it
feels tacked on, maybe pulling
focus from that really original
idea about synthetic sincerity.
So the reader gets this jolt of
existential dread and then later
a kind of historical corrective.
Does it feel connected enough?
That's the question.
Are we asking the reader to do
too much work connecting the
dots between the philosophical
risk and the historical context?
So the suggestion is integrate
them, weave that historical
evidence, the Santiana angle,
into the main flow of the Sartre
in argument.
Instead of a separate block.
Right.
Let the core warning absorb that
history, engage with it
directly, and then transcend it.
It makes the final synthesis,
the main warning, feel stronger,
more grounded.
I can see that strengthening the
flow, but isn't their value in
presenting it as a distinct
counter?
Doesn't that show intellectual
honesty, acknowledging the other
side fully?
That's a fairpoint, we don't
want to lose that nuance, but
you can maintain that honesty by
integrating the history as
context or specific counter
examples within the main
argument rather than a full
separate rebuttal.
OK, so for instance, how would
that look?
Well a concrete example instead
of the whole separate section.
Bring in Lincoln or MLK using
American ideals or those anti
war vets reclaiming the flag.
Bring those examples in earlier.
And use them to contrast to say
this is what they did, but the
current performance is different
because.
Exactly.
It sharpens the critique.
It highlights the difference
between what the writer sees as
authentic civic evolution versus
this specific synthetic managed
version they're worried about.
The history then serves to
clarify the present danger.
Or another way, maybe use the
historical shifts in language.
You know how belonging was
talked about from 1776 versus
2001.
Use that as scaffolding within
the body paragraphs.
Yeah, build it in.
So the conclusion can then
circle back hard to the main
point.
Belief enforced from above, even
with historical nods, is still
control.
It keeps the focus on that
institutional bad faith idea.
That works beautifully.
It keeps the rigor but improves
the narrative Dr. significantly.
OK, which brings us, I think to
the core warning, learning
itself, this United States of
HR, the sincerity by decree,
it's a really chilling concept.
How do we make that land with
maximum impact?
That's the final piece.
To really make that central
warning hit home, the
performance becoming real in the
worst way.
We need to translate those
powerful but abstract ideas into
very concrete, recognizable
examples.
That's our third topic sentence.
Right now the language is
evocative.
Definitely moral nationalism,
fusing empathy with control.
The flag as a compliance symbol,
A smile with paperwork attached.
Great phrases.
Absolutely killer phrases, but
the weakness is that they remain
slightly philosophical, a bit
generalized.
It makes it harder for the
reader to really picture the
everyday reality of this
managerial control being
critiqued.
What does it feel like?
We need to take the Sartre in
bad faith out of the seminar
room and put it into the office.
Maybe.
Exactly so the suggestion is
provide vivid practical
illustrations show how this
moral nationalism manifests in
actual contemporary settings,
corporate life, institutions,
culture.
Ground the abstract risk in
tangible outcomes.
Make that compliance symbol
something you have to click on.
OK, Yeah.
So, thinking about that flag as
a compliance symbol, how does
that actually show up on a
Tuesday morning?
Well, concretely maybe it looks
like mandatory love of country,
love of justice training modules
you have to complete for your
performance review.
Framed as Wellness or belonging,
not politics.
Or tying national holidays like
Memorial Day or July 4th to
hitting specific corporate
diversity and inclusion metrics
so expressing patriotism becomes
literally a KPI.
Oh yeah, imagine that quarterly
review.
Your civic belonging score is
below target.
That makes the managerial
control instantly, painfully
real.
That's concrete and the
therapeutic state idea.
How does dissent get managed?
We need to illustrate that too,
not through force, but through
emotional or managerial framing.
So maybe examples like public
shaming campaigns or specific
language codes where disagreeing
isn't just wrong, it means you
lack belonging or have moral
resentment.
Basically pathologizing dissent.
Precisely if you don't perform
the required sincerity, you're
not just incorrect, you're
psychologically flawed.
Maybe need counseling.
That's how the smile with
paperwork attached becomes truly
chilling.
It translates bad faith into HR
policy.
OK, this is really shaping up.
It's already such a strong
analysis tying philosophy to the
present moment.
These three areas seem key to
making it even sharper.
Absolutely.
So to re tap the actionable
advice, first clarify that
Hegelian structure.
Either streamline the terms or
if keeping multiple synthesis,
explicitly define the function
of each stage.
Got it.
Second, weave the historical
counter arguments directly into
the main essay.
Use the Santana perspective and
historical examples to enrich
and challenge the Sartre and
warning from within, not from a
separate section.
Right.
Make it part of the flow.
And 3rd, make that central
warning about sincerity by
decree concrete.
Translate the abstract
philosophical dangers into
vivid, specific examples of
institutional, corporate, or
cultural control that readers
can immediately recognize.
It's excellent material already.
These suggestions are really
about maximizing its coherence
and its urgency for the reader.
Exactly.
It's high caliber work.
We think these refinements will
really elevate its impact.
We're definitely looking forward
to seeing how these ideas might
be incorporated.
Please feel free to implement
these suggestions and send the
revised work back.
Progressive patriotism and the
American dialectic.
OK, So what we're looking at
here is how the progressive left
seems to be really leaning into
patriotism lately.
But it feels kind of like a
performance, right?
And the worry, like the
philosopher Jean Paul Sartre
warned, is that this act could
actually become a real belief.
And that could seriously change
things in American culture.
First off, there's this core
danger Sartre called bad faith.
Basically, it's like self
deception.
You pretend to be something and
then poof, you actually become
it.
So the left's current patriotic
vibe, you know, things like no
Kings rallies, maybe it started
as mimicry.
But hey, in America, pretending
has often been step one to
actually becoming something,
right?
The risk this pretend patriotism
gets real hardens into this kind
of self-righteous official
nationalism that doesn't feel
genuine.
Second, let's talk about what's
driving this shift.
Think of it like a political
back and forth.
You had the sort of managerial,
technocratic mood of the 20
tens.
Then the populist MAGA thing
pushed back against that.
Now the left's move, this great
patriotic heist is kind of like
the next step they're taking
populist style, mixing social
justice talk with Revolutionary
War vibes, basically trying to
create this synthetic
patriotism.
And finally, what's the
potential outcome here?
Well, the sources warned about a
new standard, a kind of diverse,
corporate approved patriotism
where sincerity is like,
professionalized and freedom
starts looking a lot like just
going along.
But this kind of forced
sincerity, it's almost
guaranteed to spark a reaction
down the line, a new rebellion
looking for something, you know,
raw and real, not managed.
So the essential take away it's
that the American story often
moves in these cycles where
today's political performance
becomes tomorrow's official
belief, which then just tease up
the next pushback against
feeling managed.